well Monday I just had a voodoo doughnut
because it's your birthday Brendan's
happy she found out ten seconds for we
walked in yes I did why the [ __ ] are
there go because I wasn't what is my
birthday but I wasn't invited to the to
the dinner party right and I thought
that that's when your birthday was
I still didn't get a text I'll be
birthday on that day there dude well I'm
gonna send you a lot I'm gonna send you
some great text today okay I might even
post something on Instagram nope too
late what do you mean too late bro dude
it's your bird nope if you remembered
he'd post first thing in the morning
come on don't make one right now what
we're doing the podcast you know what I
mean
nope it's too forced but no but it's not
to force it better than ever that did on
king of sting she did I'm finding the
kid that's no man it's it's Brendan's
birthday and happy birthday to the one
and only twenty three twenty thirty six
years only three years old thick skin
knowing me three well I don't get it 23
you know you think so pretty established
23 year old really mm-hmm
there is drinking has come bucho for his
gut he's got a little tummy ache after
Miami what what do you what anything
anything to say on your birthday dude
for real for the kid feels good to be 24
years old nope you're 36 though you
can't go into denial now it only gets
worse from here but what do you have to
say you're at the top of your game
what do you would are you any advice for
anybody yeah suck my dick there you go
kid oh my god alright alright man well
that was our video that's our video dude
yeah man it's my it's my birthday
camouflage and corduroy so you can't
just go camouflage you got to go
corduroy all in underneath you know this
is yeah who is it dude that's Mets
yep it's the Mets yeah at all but it's a
special Jersey I know exactly who that
is who you asking me who wore that the
cocaine a guy named Darryl Strawberry
the cocaine cowboy himself row yeah it's
a special birthday Jersey for that ass
that's right a phenomenal I hope you get
some money for that does he seem money
for the jerseys I don't care I don't
know he got paid he robbed the Yankees
in the meth of so much money yeah with
his cocaine habit and it didn't really
work out yep God his nose was made for
snorting cocaine he did a lot easy to
get all the Ryan aina all of it yeah you
don't want to be at a cooking part of
that do
no one ever did a lot of cocaine and it
got better
you'd never disagree there's some great
actors and directors who do all shitload
of coke well I don't think that their
careers get better their careers get
worse I heard I heard Al Pacino needed
of shitload of blood you took a long
time off remember from sea of love took
a yeah but made phone magic well hi well
sure but not necessarily hi oh [ __ ]
a talented guy who had a substance abuse
problem maybe should I be nice sure he
had the well document they said Nirvana
did how about the doors you think Jim
Moore sort of wrote those songs not
being on I did I do
I do actually there's a there's a
there's a really interesting debate well
gone through to the other side but the
idea they don't dead right crazy people
do drugs not true it's there are some
creative people that have substance
abuse problems and they they despite
that they end up doing something but
there's a book called the dark stuff by
Nick Kent as a rock journalist makes a
really interesting argument and sort of
Stephen King by the way a really
interesting argument for how drugs
actually destroyed especially not weed
in psychedelics whedon psychedelics
surprisingly especially psychedelics may
you can make the argument enhance
certain people's expression but when you
get into ready when you get into the
heroine link oh no no and the coke huh
yeah that's right they see that's what
kills a psychedelic psychedelics and
wheat sure like you're not writing whole
just [ __ ] without well you could but I
mean there's no doubt that when the
Beatles got into psychedelics I think
the White Album and all those great I
mean so there's no doubt that I would
imagine psychedelics can be an enhancing
property again within reason but cocaine
and heroin they've been a lot of books
and a lot of like essays written on how
that disturbing where you'll create
really doesn't make you feel yeah it
just killed a lot of young creative
people not even killed people yeah
Hendricks at 27 Janis Joplin 27 Kurt
Cobain 27 even though he killed himself
but he was doing cocaine I've seen the
documentary hold on II love probably had
them probably and then there was uh and
then there was Janis Joplin and then Jim
Morrison so all of them at 27
that's young the Dodger 27 yeah yeah he
was taking sleeping pill
it's in 2715 50 what he said Brendan
Schaub 27 when he's 7 yeah
how about Tarek my boy Tarkas II my I
see him this weekend had a blast you
insane into that yeah but he goes
something about you guys I just you know
I just get worried I go why he goes all
the good ones in my life go I don't want
you to die I was like hey bro I'm not
gonna [ __ ] die y'all older I mean goes
through people's head yeah well hold on
now if you're a kid it make would be
weird but you aren't you're not young
I'm 50 - yeah I thought about life when
you pass you kidding me excuse me
look what am I gonna die from I just had
my checkup and the doctor was like the
worst rice as I've ever seen mine 36
years on this planet yeah you had got
shingles on your four and have some
shingles okay okay who knows what's
gonna get you know it seems like shits
up popping up like stresses over my skin
all right as you get older
[ __ ] apodaca went holy [ __ ] when he saw
me with your shirt off with you now it
just went yeah I you beautiful man I was
like you guys you're a beautiful man he
goes no says he goes you're always in
here
nurses running is in him well the
problem is I don't I don't stick to one
job doctor I got too many yeah so I
never so tart said all the good ones in
his life path away well he was just
talking about yeah gosh I know it was a
little bad news big tarik me Tarkin
Yosef this weekend went pheasant hunting
in Sonoma how was it and killing
innocent bird III got some birds we you
do with the dog the dog which is a
German Shorthaired runs around and when
it sees a dog a pheasant roosting it
points now you know pheasants my
favorite meat of all time okay so I'm
already dying of hunger and and then the
dog you go go and the dog flushes it the
dog goes after it some news sometimes
I'll catch it as a duck hunt so nice the
pheasants a little slow the dog catch
them at one point the pheasant tried to
fly out and the dog grabbed it and held
it in his mouth but they have a soft
mouth and so it didn't try to kill it
and I let it go and then the bird flew
again didn't shot it in the face up
close well I had to yeah it's not yeah I
had to take it out yeah now now I'm
surprised at how quickly how many times
tarik myself and ghost have missed
a bird actually would not yeah what we
get shot guns shot guts like duck duck
I had a small shotgun got a bruise on my
on my little army part me because
there's yeah it hurts it starts to hurt
when you're when you're a bit of a [ __ ]
like myself but like you run with that
duck and then did you guys spasm so you
gotta say it right good duck but it's a
fast man than that look at that poor
thing what bothers me is your laziness
with the English language just how poor
of that the poor little thing yeah how's
it tough to ski see him in the clear
skies and the huge shotgun you [ __ ]
yeah and by the way Hoff there's
nothing's it's not out of the year it's
not a real sport no they shot in the
field so they breed of course and they
stock the field like shooting an edition
of bill in there basically I only do it
because it's so tattoo tasting did you
guys even like I will say this about
hunting I know you're gonna think I'm a
[ __ ] you like I don't like karate right
nope too late look at the picture
do you like after you did it maybe you
know I don't really enjoy killing them
now while you're doing it I can look at
this Bros shotgun kill another one [ __ ]
these things yeah and now you're gonna
get some [ __ ] you need to take some
heat online you're like you know what I
actually didn't enjoy any of it well I
don't like the actual slaying of the
deer but I like the meat so much then I
will do it and I'll do it
good so whenever I have an opportunity
yeah you do it good yeah I do it good
and I'm rather good shot because I'm
terrified of wounding the animals so I
want to put it out right away I'm not a
hunter dude no but we should do our meat
eater together and yeah they still try
and do that yeah we should really do
that you know but I like the hunting
when you have to track the animal like
with a pack on our back like men yeah
but then you get the yet all the
technology or sleep in sleeping bags I'm
trying to do it the real way we need
knives it bow and arrows I'm saying no
you you want guns and [ __ ] well bone
arrows you got to practice the animal
yeah I'll sit behind the cambia yeah get
that [ __ ] oh so you're gonna be the S
you're gonna be the cider like so with
smile my flavor flav of you have a guy
who looks like a flavor hunting
oh I'm the height man so you don't
actually pull the did okay you're just
like yeah you got his camp yeah
you got this yeah I got that think and
God yeah I'm gonna let's eat this
yeah Camp is can shape right he's coming
out I was like dude you want to do a
quick half marathon I'm like mmm no you
know what didn't respond back no I'm
gonna be honest be honest I didn't
respond back this text pretended I
didn't see that's a giant rock look at
that that's what she said Wow
yeah that's a big one that's real
hunting kids dude you missed a good time
in Miami man my fight good time well I
was kind of thinking oh yeah you had an
IV a shit-filled get my body my joints
hurt my back hurt really can down oh did
you have a little fluey flu or what I
don't know Jay thinks I did but I don't
know Athena
we're okay now inside of it I'm all
right now so what you did at that little
you had that little sicky-sick poo for a
little bit right where I lost you as a
lace yeah and then maybe you ate
something did you eat something no it
would last this long
you got the squirts yeah it's not good
now that voodoo doughnut helped keep you
stable what are you talking about cuz I
tan entire chocolate glazed donut my
favorite donut shoutout to Cal for
bringing them I'm washing it down with
[ __ ] kombucha yeah yeah I'm trying to
[ __ ] my pants on there I would have I
would have won a little bite and then I
had to eat those out there this is so
soft
yeah they make that literally you cannot
beat a trumpet glazed donut from voodoo
it's a it's a gluten bomb it's what
every nutritionist would tell you to
avoid bo but it's so good and I don't
care nutritious don't know [ __ ] right
you gotta live a little you have to live
a little like anyone been on their
deathbed like wish I didn't eat that
doughnut correct no they're probably I
wish I wasn't [ __ ] vegan forever
that's what I feel like it's like you
know I guess you could live a little
longer but you know food a huge part of
life also past 85 you're just playing
with the houses car yeah let's get real
here yeah after 85 yeah
come on it's all smooth sailing just be
grateful man yeah that's true
I agree those look nice though what else
what else was your weekend about so
Miami what did you do during the day
dude me and Jay Walker alia it's so
sacred new [ __ ] during the day
poor ji word Cuban food to the room
weird Cuban food of it so we ate there
Jay farting up a storm so we ate in the
room
Jade all the Cuban food in the world
yeah and then we watched Duke basketball
because they're sure the gift that keeps
on giving
yep and then we do shows that night dude
Oh Tony and Glen were out there turning
Toni Jeffries and Glen
oh really Wayne oh that's awesome
they're out there doing their
certifications yeah love those so they
came to the show on Friday um let me ask
you this and it's just a question they
do they make uh know that was gonna ask
you that's all don't please don't give
yourself sorry Don don't exaggerate
right where are you measuring from the
anus no keep go Kay you go so um they
make a good-looking person out there
Miami there's not a flat ass to be seen
not a flat ass to be seen and not a flat
not a flat shoe to be seen I think the
women wear high heels to the dresses and
even the dudes earned three-piece suits
right mean Jay lights it we look like
undercover cops
we didn't dress very well out I love the
way they dress Manny that's that Latin
that cute so weird how about our vibe
everyone's given them in it was in our
amazing club man oh so I've been open
for six months the new one yeah
but though the way they run it has this
young vibe they're marketing like the
place was ridiculous man I've written a
poem one poem in my life one poem in my
god I don't want to hear it I would
never read it to you god I ruin about
Miami then did you suck dick after
Sandman don't be so aggressive I wrote a
poem about Miami that's how much I loved
it and sent it to dove the whole eye
about ah about being pale an American
and how badly I want to be Cuban you
want to be tan I wrote a poem that's how
much I love Miami look I have a I have a
weird love for Miami really see I don't
I'm not again maybe as I get all our
appreciate like I don't really
appreciate in New York two last songs
out there I Love New York now buthe
Miami I've never I don't know man I just
yeah it's cool great club my deaf I'll
always go back to that Club phenomenal
Club yeah
but Miami just in general doesn't do it
for me I don't know I don't go out I
like restaurants I don't like the whole
getup
you know I don't know I want to I want
to be I think I'd want to be moved in
Miami yeah and I want to dance I want to
be a professional salsa dancer I want to
take it seriously you could do it there
I want to work my debt I want my day to
be like [ __ ] my my left my left step
is not I'm not I'm not turning when I
should have it I didn't read that
properly I want to have that
conversation either did you think so
you could do that chin you've been to
Miami yes sir well when did you go to
Miami many many many years ago chin
you're not you're not so Miami you know
not that I wouldn't say [ __ ] like when I
think of Chennai on Shan doesn't scream
I am whoa yeah you know I don't think of
chin as Miami cat have you been to Miami
no no that's more Miami I know I can see
getting catty neither one of them are
Miami you know yeah you don't mind me
either a big excuse me of you you know
what you aren't bro hold on you're so
fine knows he's gonna have you've never
seen me know I've seen you open up hey
this is gonna sting a tad I need you to
take this on my birthday you Boca ratone
[Music]
you have been waiting oh man you're
having this waiting room oh my god your
heavens waiting room you I can't wait
hey if there's a sign and it's saying
who's more Miami that arrows pointed
sure the [ __ ] I'll give you that broke
over time how you can't dance in your
staff yeah but in your case [ __ ] and you
don't live in your hips but but here's
the thing you do have a look that fits
me a me you don't need as much sunblock
as I do and but when I get my eyes done
when I get my eyes done I can do that
out there actually met son who does it I
got it
they said they'd do it for you my
cousin's a plastic surgeon out there
step down first stand down for a second
while I'm talking now want to get my
eyes done yeah okay and it really goes
south I'll be in Miami when you need me
yeah if you ask me my age and yes young
lady next to me my age as I'm dancing
she will look at you right in the eye
and go he's 41 years old
40 points 41 cuz it ma'am is where I
take 10 years off my age now if I have
to bet on where you can be in ten years
ya be out of the business Six Feet Under
you here's gonna be gone if I'm renting
a spot on a yacht in Miami
don't say that dude don't say about
don't say that about my hair because
there's a lot of Technology don't say
that you here's gonna be gone hey you
here's me gone yeah you ready yeah give
me a mascot at a retirement no I don't
want to be like hey let's get this go
and it let's bingo you're me doing
stand-up in Boca ratone
really yep [ __ ] man
what's going on who wants to play bingo
hey Mildred a lot of wrinkles in here am
i right
ha ha lot of wrinkles and hey anybody
using condoms I'm just kidding nobody
here can get pregnant I've seen I've
seen younger faces on cash
that's it you that he's not my jokes or
tosses joke thank you Pokhara ton dude
you're more Boca Raton bye boy oh boy
Boca Raton you ever been there though I
have Lex lived there he does nation's
Naples
I'm just not Florida guy I don't know
I'm a Miami guy not maybe as I get away
Palm Beach ain't bad right yeah a little
limited though right a little old too
yeah Miami I got it you know maybe my
experience you gotta be careful when you
spend a weekend there and then say that
I you extrapolate that I could live
there to hold the truth right true thing
is when we go to places like you know
it's such a blast because you're on
vacation yeah you're like me and Jay
warming Jay and I were eating we stay at
the Four Seasons we're outside on the
ocean and I was like you know people who
start about vacations like this my work
kind of it all comes together I don't
have to go on vacation vacation Emma
being Holmes my vacation right that's
how I feel that's how I don't jump on my
training right now I don't need a
vacation you do though you know with
your shingles and should I don't have
shows anymore all right all right dude
how about uh you forgot how's my
birthday whether I want to talk about it
it's tough to remember things well no
but I just assumed that you should but I
just assume people don't remember
birthdays because it's hard for me to
remember adapt it Oh hopefully someone
just post them on Instagram well my
friends like oh yeah it's their birthday
when do you really remember birthdays
right not really
rogon on his 50th I think called some
people and told him that he appreciated
them including me when he turned 50 yeah
like I was in while I was in Utah I just
got a call from my guys man I appreciate
the [ __ ] Adi mystical Mindy I was like
that's a nice thing to say I don't know
how you made this birthday so he was all
in fact I would rather I'd rather I'd
rather give gifts and receive get well
that's what I'm saying like they called
the people that he approves ence I'm a
fan of I'm a fan of celebrating a
stopping and celebrating certain moments
in your life I think that's important
actually
you should write that as a Hallmark card
I think it's very important I think I
think if you keep going and you never
make those marks you you're gonna regret
it I do think it's a hobby and you think
you stop and do that I did that with my
50th birthday what do you talk about the
one we had at your house yeah
I got everybody together fan I did write
well but I but for me that's kind of
stuff is important to just stop for a
second and get people together that you
know and look at them all like these do
you have to do on your birthday you
don't know it was an excuse
yeah yeah you only await your birthday
no hey you don't know if like you want
but I just think it's important like
like when you win certain laws and get 3
miles to 50 yeah but 50 is important
because and I'm not trying to be funny
here but we all know you're you're like
you're in the back like I'm not trying
to be funny at all we're in the back not
so it's like fifties important to be
like what's up already I have no idea I
know from here I'm not gonna get better
looking car noggin gets smarter correct
I'm gonna get some health concerns I'm
not trying to be funny at all that's
just real after 50 life gets old your
user you want to acknowledge everyone
you become more limited right in your
scope and things but but I think that
that's what I mean that they're kind of
but also you know marking milestones
when you accomplish something even if
it's a special by the way number one on
iTunes thank you everybody for
downloading it that's awesome
complicated apes but that was a big deal
like I stopped and I was like oh that's
that's pretty cool like I don't know how
long that'll last it doesn't matter
like just taking a minute to like cuz
there's a tendency when you're type-a or
whatever you want to call it to never do
that I I would never do that you just
keep going yeah cuz you're nervous about
the future and you try it you know I
don't know I think
good idea I don't know either did cuz
anyway what's the point what is the
point so if you're if you're going
somewhere what are you trying to what's
the end game and what's that look like
for what like for real no shut up
creating cool [ __ ] and that for why
making money why money for security so
you do what are the [ __ ] you want okay
but what would what is doing whatever
the [ __ ] you want right you're looking
at it yeah okay like we don't have a
boss right that was always my thing I
don't want a boss no I'm telling you
about I worried you
it's nice I near buzz I don't know that
you're fired what you're rehired
yeah that works dude yep you're back man
that got me so insecure in fire let's
see what the fire in your back cat get
out it yeah your back dude you have a
lot of power don't do that to me again
because it will see you're getting a
little media flushes alright
I don't want rice and you're fired ah
and your rap ah [ __ ] Derrick you rack
your egg it's not funny man I am sorry
cuz I need I need I need this money
later I have bills and you're fired what
my skin I know let that send you back
you're rehired I can't deal with this
[ __ ] emotional rollercoaster
sometimes I need to flex on you guys
everyone it's a little too comfortable
in there see if like those donuts or
soggy cat you're fired
and you're back cuz they weren't we see
how everyone's like yeah you keep us up
John I walk in your life ever had my
acting teacher hit me that one time he
goes he goes this is terrible what
you're doing I was like in front of 80
people and all people like who are my
peers well I'm and who were successful
actors I was really nervous and he goes
what is this what is what are you doing
what are you doing like are you doing
this a show for us or you can actually
look at the person in front of you and I
was like hmm and I was you know you're
trying to make it in acting you go I
maybe I suck at acting
I'm only 32 33 and I suck and maybe this
isn't for me right and go I don't what I
mean
what would it would it what is this like
can we do acting how did you get in this
class this is what I get and then you go
cook you want to do this again or you
want to sit down
I'd be like I'll do it again and then I
I [ __ ]
do really well and he goes you know what
happens when I when I get you off your
pin you'll be about you start to act
yeah yellow to comfy-cozy yeah I was
like I'd like you to be off your pins
most of the football don't like you
comfortable coaches do it all the time
too you do all the time you go like
you're so incite kind of go through the
most um like that you'd show up
that Tuesday and there'd be a depth
chart and you'd be second string like
what the [ __ ] but they'd only do it for
like two days
oh and then they'd bring you back like
you you've played well enough we're
gonna make you starter now we're really
there didn't have you start whole time
but yeah it's good
jeffrey tambor in class in front of
everybody I guess I hadn't done a scene
in a little while and went though here's
the thing about life when you do well in
class or you gotta get a job
you put you relax a little bit you relax
it maybe I've made it maybe I'm maybe
I'm just a little more advanced I'll let
these other people get a shot class goes
looking around you guys hey Brian you
are you done being the mayor I'm just
curious
are you dumb being the mayor saying hi
to everybody and being the most popular
kid in class because we're we're doing
acting so when when you're ready to do
some more scenes we'd appreciate it or
are you gonna be the mayor in front of
everybody I'm a Croma but then there's
Sarah sit there there's some people like
Michael Jordan or some of these ultra
winners I'm sure maybe Brad Pitt who you
never take they get a little success and
then as soon as you open the door a
little it's game it's cookies habit
you're never gonna get it back it's a
habit as far as like you open a door
they're gonna take him out yes yes and
they're still not happy well that that's
an interesting question to what's what's
driving you is it this whole you can't
fill for me i discomfort the success can
be like when you start accomplishing it
gets its gets uncomfortable because it's
a responsibility for a thousand reasons
so it's really easy to pull back once
you the biggest thing that people would
do with acting in is once they get a job
[ __ ] with their scene work everything
would go down a hill because they do the
job and then they did they take a mini
vacation like you'd get it like the
worst is you'd get a TV show and the
grind of pilot season was so hot song it
up and so stress cutscenes going on
right now right yeah it's different now
it used to be you had a basically a
month-to-month window when you went on
our dish five auditions today if you
lucky if you were like me and you had an
agent and all that if you didn't get
that you you basically went to ten
months without work kind of it it sucked
so you had that distance same intensity
wherever there's no second place only on
the only one person gets that part and
look at and when you book it man you'd
never want to go through that again and
that question dad do you go on auditions
right no no no no I put everything on
pause once I started working and you're
fired
don't you pursue your dream no how did
you Eugene please see your back back
walk anybody made you uncomfortable got
you to pursue him and then he fires you
is like you know i'ma stay here yeah
thank you for the opportunity
yes nice dude you're you're an actually
a really good motivator thanks man I
could have always used that I could have
always used somebody and I'm being
serious get fired motivate you need your
fire I know I needed a whip somebody
with a [ __ ] whip to go hey bro you
haven't arrived
stop relaxing yeah yeah but more of my
problems just details yeah what's the
little details little whippy whip just
just not being ready you know but
everybody goes through that not everyone
no but you know yeah everyone has their
course you know huh
everyone has their pass that course and
you're fired because you're annoying
who you're annoying me no please Liz
when you went well everyone no no you're
fired
okay I'm sorry if all right you guys
you're back my skin I don't know why you
guys made me do this today on my
birthday man mmm there's a little
alcohol and kombucha and I started
drinking you know they make hard
kombucha where they're like I go full
out yeah I wouldn't want to get hammered
off kombucha you know yeah you don't
like to do now before every show I take
Google's shot of Jack try to just go to
Jack you loosey goose before you go
onstage that's how it starts that's what
I'm thinking
yeah because because I did it usually I
do it just before the first show the
Miami I'm like it's Miami there's fat
asses everywhere let's take a shot
before the first and second show hmm but
shot for you your big boy
mmm not a drink of that you know so not
used to it'll loosen you up a little
tipsy tipsy I got drunk when Sonoma
twelve we were done by noon and Phil
knows in a submerged
and he had he was putting quail and lamb
that locally raised lamb marinated week
style on an open flame I bet that was
nice
other lambs walked in the background
though no no they were just down you
ever been a restaurant does that now
that that farm-to-table look at him like
no no yeah but that that kind of food
and he was the thing a group of guys
next to us guy comes out with so we're
eating lamb and we're eating some
tomatoes right and that's it it's kind
of like a sparse kind of Kiro thing but
I'm drinking very good wine got a little
drunk here was what was fascinating
sitting there in these three four dudes
come up and go guys but you boys were
farting huh no I don't know where this
story's going oh yeah so he comes up and
he goes he just he just puts this
steaming hot loaf of bread that he had
just made a weird I thought it's going
elsewhere and and and I've never looked
at something I was like hey like and
they're cutting it up and they're eating
this you know when you cut the bread and
it's stands up with that cross it's a
good brand their line eat that really
with cheese and salami and I'm like [ __ ]
yeah I mean this but I love a little
piece of bread I'm like you mind if I
smell your breath you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it was a bread walls you get a piece not
if nothing may stave not at all I've not
have ordered mad the guy made it they
say like good good bread with you know
as is it's important absolutely you can
eat good bread hell yeah you can Oh what
the stuff that Europe was built on
sourdough up that all of the Middle East
eats a nice sour door come on come on
what let us live what like a nice
Ezekiel my says he kills not yet
something new on that ass walnut milked
uh I do oat milk walnut milk walnut I
never heard a lob walnuts [ __ ] can you
milk me yeah they're delicious yeah
walnut milk you like like a nutty melt
in your mouth
this is nuttier than almond well can I
tell you what my doctor this morning
said when I had my checkup everyone so I
cut again gladder and your fight you
know healthy five but as an agnolotti
girl it was an annual checkup man please
you're back so you know they have to
check your balls no they can hook your
balls every time you go he goes yeah he
goes he put I have to wear black panties
and then he goes we're done why man why
and he goes nuts the dentist that's the
best but he goes up to me he goes let's
see the boys Oh cause I well alright
here we go
old is he uh 48 is your doctor Harrison
Ford why does it sound like that right
now let's see the boys younger than me
and did he see the boys saw the boys in
a massage room yeah you got me coughing
yeah he does all that you know what he
did you know what he didn't do it didn't
stick his finger in my ass to check my
prostate they don't really do that as
much anymore why so because if there's a
an issue with a prostate a lot of people
will they do a biopsy which actually
causes more problems than otherwise in
other words they'll do a biopsy on your
prostate and you have impotence and it
can cause more problems so now they do a
blood test and they have to look at a
lot of other stuff yes shinnok up the
idea of sticking your finger in a cup
have you done that I sure haven't see I
heard well I did well for a stool sample
for mice rises back in the day will you
you do you've done so much stuff I
thought yeah yeah I remember at the
shinik cup yeah I didn't have to [ __ ] in
the cup I just you just swab it
it's disgust Oh putting it in a tube oh
hey how about that laughs enjoy that
just all day looking at poof no I get I
got one screw this
no how about at the fertility clinic and
the dude just hand you little baggie and
then takes you to the room and you got a
bust in the cup really and he has to set
everything up he's like in the pornos up
here this is old-school TVs like and
you're porns in here you just you go
through it there's a DVD I'm like throw
her out
get the [ __ ] out give me much I got a
cell phone you [ __ ] yeah I'm not why
he goes then when you're done just bring
it back we'll be waiting there there's a
line of six dudes like a [ __ ] vintage
that's we're all room waiting to give
him our sample that's off and then you
know what he does he on does the lunch
bag it's a lunch bag he looks at it
shakes it puts it in the freezer see
you're kind plus you're come and are
recognizable so it's a little like I
just used to want to be dealing with
getting recognized oh there's a fan
there who worked there said something
really yeah oh that's that's just what's
up dude I just got a fertility issue
what's up dude dropping loads my man
what did what they say about your load
what do you mean we getting personal now
or no I'm nobody's let something good to
go over something good to go well good
thing about this podcast everybody knows
everything about us I'm good to go they
said oh you are yeah everything swims
well and all that yeah what are we
looking for do you know much about it uh
yeah they're looking for how many
swimmers are in per like there's a
certain number of liters and [ __ ] and
how many are you supposed to have I
forget there's a shitload though when
you get on things like testosterone as
opposed to zero it does yeah the guy was
saying cuz he they add me fill out all
this questionnaire and then he goes I
got asked yeah he doesn't see me kind
uncomfortable I'm like no it's gonna ask
about girls or something like that
and he goes have you ever done TRT no
yours off thank God he goes kiss the
guys come in here about proms who aren't
TRT he was I and he's girls I've been
doing it for a long time he works with
everyone he's been doing for a long time
he goes usually their sperm cam is zero
Wow cuz their ball shot yeah is a very
rare their sperm count is anything he
goes and then they can't have kids then
they complain I guess where they do he
goes you have to get off it for at least
three to six months cold turkey Wow Wow
yeah I'm sure if more guys knew that TRT
does that they wouldn't take it like hey
so he can meet Jax all your bros think
you look cool and have acne all over
your back so you're not gonna be able to
have kids
don't [ __ ] yeah yeah but I don't think
guys know that well there's a lot of
stuff about whenever you talk to guys
people are always pushing it on me and
they're always making so much sense
everybody's like you got to see my
doctor this animal is like yes I need it
though I just don't feel like I need it
and but it prolongs life and I don't
know man yeah all right I'm not
impressing that guy's terrible but just
makes your skin a little tighter I don't
give off [ __ ] about that
oh they're older guys though there you
go looks good yeah I look get in the
middle though too
he looks good all the way through right
let's run with him on the left I feel
like it's the same guy just better on
the left I feel like a no necked
do you hold a meth on the far right
right he doesn't face that's what I mean
your skin flushes that are on the left
yeah I feel like sometimes guys look
better on but here's the thing though I
I think with
[ __ ] Christ oh god he's you're looking
broke God nobody's frustrate I mean man
in are you sir are you an alien
are you from another planet I'm what
planet do we think that is normal no
give it up what's with the [ __ ] what
the [ __ ] yes we had some that terrible
swim know what about its tits
what about what about the lazy right
titty I don't know how do you have a
lazy tit one Rambo might they have a
huge what there's a huge gap like their
actual tits between the two you know my
[ __ ] face Sylvester all old is he now
I'm never doing his movies now but
whatever
hey the thing is about semester Stallone
hears thing about trt there's no and I
we don't know it is brand new so we
don't have enough research on it but
there's no way that let's it's like
putting a supercharger on your car yeah
well your car didn't have the parts to
run that supercharger for that long
right so isn't it like your body you
supposed to have a certain level of
testosterone yeah and then when you're
putting more and more into it you're on
a nitric oxide and your body's like dude
we're gonna bust somewhere along the
lines here our veins are made to handle
this much tat from what I've heard
sometimes your lipid levels you have to
really be that's why you get checked
every three months because it can [ __ ]
with your lipid levels and all kinds of
stuff like your a cholesterol and stuff
yeah so I don't know I I think the
process though whoa
I'll tell you what though if someone
said hey you start feeling better you
taking I probably take it but unique in
doctors come to the house yeah well Jeff
Bezos is definitely memory of Jeff Bezos
listen if Jeff Bezos is taking it he has
he's my resources yeah is looks way
better you listen he has six billion
more dollars in you at least
oh no but he's got a lot more than that
buddy I know 300 billion is it 300
richest man in the world that's right
well his wife second richest you know
that shut up to that that's very just an
image not [ __ ] you know I mean but if
Jeff Bezos has taken it yeah and he has
though access to the smartest minds in
the world probably something to it huh I
would have guy I think test I think Elon
Musk is taking it too I'm sure a lot of
people I'm sure that it worked those
guys are so smart don't you think it was
that bad for either one take it
you think that sounds bad I think it's
bad for you at all I think I don't I
don't think it's bad for you I think
there's too much there's too much
evidence it's been doing so long the
people there are no bodies out there
I worry a little bit about human growth
hormone right that that's a little bit
strange to me a boy Robbie Williams
Robin we'll have you thought about it
Robbie - Robbie you know works with
Robbie Williams
Oh Tony Jeffries is it easy as
instructor nice Jeff Bezos got jack well
boy yeah
Brogan poster boy for it yeah you want
for 10 years more than that dan
Bilzerian Mel Gibson yeah
special own nobody yet he's been doing
since the 70s so he's in his 70s but
yeah he's been doing it since demolition
man okay that much dude you don't think
he on all the steroids were [ __ ]
rocky when he brought you come out well
Rocky was 77 now I got the balls before
now you can say oh come on I don't think
that Belfort he was drinking eggs no but
you see a huge difference in Rocky 3
100% he was doing event he's on all of
it you know I can just do it for Rocky 3
not right well I think it was before
people knew enough like I then then it
became then he started hanging out with
bodybuilders and those guys well I can
come over here
you know maybe no chin I think chin I
thought you were gonna do it I didn't
get tested yet I'm tell you I'm not an
expert low testosterone no my brother
has high testosterone you're not your
brother
still we're the same family it doesn't
matter it seems that way cuz I'm just
show how dad likes olives I hate him
doesn't matter dude possible possible it
all depends
see his body looks like Jays right there
your brother that looks like Jake she
knob that does look like Jake shop how
about Booker T Lane or whatever the [ __ ]
his name was was so jab a pro football
so Jack that's a real real I saw him at
ground works in Venice he's huge still
oh he is [ __ ] Jack's a big man he
played rocky by the way pretty no good
actor who's good actor name oh my god oh
my god yeah that great fired hold on
um man this is where I worry about
getting I only know I'm from one thing
so I'll look it up you don't for
predator colt 45
that's him right I'm you think it's her
well person a type type in a predator
his name would be on there oh do you
just click on Apollo go back see at the
top uh there you go
what is his name challenge taken long
I'm gonna figure it out but hey pretend
you're figuring things out me no no you
got it we'll wait don't just click on
him yeah what is his [ __ ] name
[Music]
there it is
Karl weather of course [ __ ] I did not
know though Oh 45 years under 45 crawl
weathers was um he's a really good actor
actually truly and he's great in the
movie yeah all those yeah he's not small
played pro football for um I think Diddy
go to jokah pedia yeah he's running ball
you'd be the tallest running back yeah
how old is he now for possibly one
defensive end in college you know
college career Cindy go stay after he
went undrafted he started with Oakland
Raiders free agent Wow
played linebackers played seven games
for the Raiders damn he signed with BS
went back to school after that good for
him
weathers near dude then a fit lump
doesn't matter and then started acting
dude
yeah good actor you didn't know his name
though I can't believe that cuz I you
know kind only my favorite movie
probably rocky Rockies your favorite
movie of all time you know it was just
such a seminal movie it's one of the
great movies ever
Wow my dad knows this looks like Billy
Dee Williams was a famous actor and
though he's super famous and he's
awesome but he's not Carl Weathers
they look alike nope Wow my bad Jesus
Christ Jen Jen all right never mind
unbelievable dude oh here's the thing
rare jo koy call me racist for not know
Tiger Woods mom yeah well I knew I got
from [ __ ] somewhere she is Chinese
you asses she's Thai in Chinese oh I
have tried guys
you [ __ ] hook that up just to make
sure yeah look it up go to Wikipedia
Tigers Tom I'm here to say I don't know
you know collegial clack American Asian
was first named Earl Woods if you click
on that terabytes now cootie dick could
tell that woods yeah but but if you go
to that the offers there that they'll
have her on there I bet her he's Chinese
alleged chinese ancestor what there was
a family joke about an alleged chinese
ancestor no no his mom has some chinese
see see the the marriages is me click on
her in that or know if her name's there
woods and his wife divorced war a
quarter chinese right yep there you go
half time and a quarter chinese you
racist [ __ ]
I almost got some touching her to God
man's a good mix other way but I told
you is the point you were good Joe was
freaking you know Joe was like you know
God the racist and the kid I know I knew
I got that I think I saw him on thirty
four thirty or something
well what's he doing now
worse is ranking now doing well he's
doing well it's not what he's doing he's
coming back up yeah every [ __ ] week
they think he's gonna win one and he's
still on the experienced top 100 he's
like number ten most famous athletes in
the world tied for 30th right now you
know but he's trying well a lot of those
injuries like most of its mental for him
probably at home it's golf game you know
but it's golf so a lot of his mental
game yeah God the whole scandal this
girl right [ __ ] everybody else unless
she broke his yeah his face with her
with a golf ball ironic she was so hot I
know so hot he crashed his car near a
tree
remember well no remember because she
was hitting it right he was like trying
to escape yeah she's so hot she's so
rich I got it she's also got a um a twin
sister she's bawling now she's pretty
hot damn that's her man no there's no
way
no maybe yep it is dating she's dating
that guy who minds oh my god okay well
there you go
oh she moved on me I'm right there yeah
just a billionaire guy like she has a
mansion for 50 million dollars geez
I bet she's she's I bet she'd about
finding the no not seeing Chris Klein
who's that is that the guy no Chris
Klein is actor colemak own everyone no
Chris Klein is right Chris Klein or
nobody is there not talking about his
clients guy actually the cow's
relationship that blossom in a romance
and she fell in love with his money
oh well that's an interesting both yeah
oh because he's very handsome he might
be an amazing guy yeah I'm sure he is
he's not a bad-looking guy you don't
that's a bad picture he might be a very
powerful no he's a billion-dollar
super-powerful married twice and I'm
sure they've ever done before I'm sure
that had nothing to do with them getting
together one year older than me hmm cool
well you know what oh look at him yeah
well he doesn't look like Jack Nelson as
the Joker at all bring him up yeah but
he's a billionaire that's sexy to people
that guy looks a little older than me
though he looks like jack knows him way
at the makeup off is the Joker he's not
a bad no upper lip can I see keep going
with that arrow please take that arrow
over to the so you know that arrows on
the computer bride do this oh I still
have to actually compress it dude just
yachts and Ho's boats and Ho's yachts
and hos yeah what's up now tiger who's
winning now Tigers like me still me oh
my guys a billionaire mining for Ravi
yeah he looks like a powerful man yeah
he looks like geez he killed a few
people yeah he looks he looks like he's
killed some people yes it's kind of sexy
evil all right for women who's Tiger
dating I don't find him sexy at least
whatever he wants
that mouth is that you know I like any
root for your team the older gentleman I
do not the best looking guy I've ever
seen oh yeah this is just call human a
human you know not not a good looking
guy if you have a billion
she wouldn't touch him hmm well part of
who he is right
rich yeah I mean powerful rich comes
with the whole package yeah you're
attracted to people for their
accomplishments I guess is just front
lip said no I'm not coming out even a
billion dollars can give you a pamphlet
even if million dollars my lips said
yeah can't get a sharp lip no you got
some nice lips and and people spent some
money on that I like her draw line I I
enjoy that jaw line she's attractive
she's your type for me phone billionaire
she in my top thousand really not from a
billionaire I go to Miami she's probably
a classy beautiful gal I don't know you
never know right you got to know who the
person is what she like in the sack you
sack
well Tiger cheated on everyone with her
but I thought yeah but knee again tight
listen occupy a vanilla ice cream on see
that's her sister so take a look at that
I think that's her she has twin sister
by the way tiger also okay well Victor's
whole fun hat makes me look like [ __ ]
she's gorgeous do that this is the Hat I
like that hat on I like hats I'm you're
reaching now good allocate you try to be
friendly though uh
Tiger had a bunch of you ever seen
Tigers mistresses bring us up chin you
know who got him started on bounce ideas
yes I feel George Charles Barkley yeah
and start getting started getting them
gambling poor guy
okay well they're all interesting I'm
not mad at a lot of them I'm very mad
you know wait a minute all right this is
Tiger [ __ ] woods I'm very upset
it might be some more here there we go
okay it's not like we can I see table
left Lee sir
well this is up check out altars on the
top right though yeah she's hey girl
okay zoom in zoom see what's going on
they're not mad at that that that top
left sign me up
yeah
no you can keep let's go over the right
very happy you talking about the [ __ ]
I mean she looks like the sister of that
billionaire
she's our I don't know it's a bad middle
once you know one on the right though
I'm very happy with that pose on the
beach and I'm sure those hits are real
so that that I know these are much
better pick up that one in the middle
she looks like a [ __ ] Hollywood mom
or some [ __ ] but I approve of the rest
of them me I get it and they're the
exact opposite of his wife yeah that's
what's going on there
there it is this keeps going down to
nobody selfish yeah oh one out of NIH's
ups
Veronica Daniels turn about old faith
old face young body I don't think she
doesn't know she's the Bryan Callen of
women rise done yeah we make all jokes
about me anymore
now what just misses from yeah just I
was just a mess is that said I wouldn't
this interesting situation he's just
having an off night you know yeah look
at me I'm not like you love nights may
not have games leading Vegas whatever
game thought type at Tigers game there
you gotta hate that wait is holly
sampson a deaf role teacher she a pro
though uh that's uh which may be a
problem that many depict she take if
you're real teeth it looks like a porno
yeah exactly a pro chitta which is why
are proof yeah me to keep going i'm a
fan there you go dude she looks like
she'll read a book or a wrist is that's
a sexy woman right there you know her no
but she looks intelligent and she looks
like a carnivore it's like a real shoots
again goddamn wrapped she's gone get
over here now
yes she's a meat-eater yep yep real me
athletes mistress local looks perplexed
donna wonder what they do we have send
these women in a clinic where they
reduce the size of the Beverly Hills
plastic surgeon Bryant she's up the
street from us know the plastic surgeon
is talking about this look like they're
gonna hit by a tree branch so look I
don't agree Jesus Christ Rachel Shelley
you can tell who could tell that was his
nut as that is when people think of me
physically does eatin out the personal I
love this hurtful thing to me Oh
interesting
really it's very personal hurtful things
to me he says you know mistress number
one who had her lips plumped and her
breasts changed from beaded yes oh but
apparently but even though you do that
with you you don't like being taken
physically you don't like when people
look at you physically interesting okay
I love that cracks me up there you go
damn tiger did not discriminate tell you
what they like the white girls Daenerys
in shape you know what he did disagree
with me the only white girls in it yeah
only white whites only white northern
European ancestry Martin Luther King you
know that I did not inside pieces all
white is that true that's well document
I didn't know that yeah they had they
had that okay all right we're shooting
Jamie Grubbs looking every which way
oh yes okay I can't think of any worse
than having to look perfect because she
looks like she's gonna tell on you
what she's a second Alan Alan she says
she didn't tell everybody yeah there's
that it's the vibe she gives man yeah
yeah she's don't send her any dams but I
shall have to Tiger Woods though shout
out sadly he's doing better he had a bit
of a man of the people
yeah he didn't know Martin Luther King
yeah they have all these tapes they
would put records in the hotel right no
he had a lineup for me I know he had a
lot of I know he had a lot of affairs in
his life his wife said that's between me
and my husband yep
well a lot of waiting the Russell's a
lot of white gowns white pros I
appreciate it really take your anger out
on them really oh yeah and they were
pros yep you don't say and said I have a
dream to bust all over your face and it
happen don't don't soil his name or I'll
freak out on you yeah that's well
documented bro that's not like
conspiracy either no Gandhi used to take
baths with young ladies to test his
resolve you know that did it work would
he just have a raging hard-on
well well apparently the took a vow
celibacy's to [ __ ] around a lot
and then oh god one of those story
the story goes that he his mom was dying
he was having sex with a woman and
missed saying goodbye to her on her
deathbed thing and so he took this
Gandhi bait with women mmm but he did
have apparently to take baths imagine
that Twitter storm by the way imagine
that the truth is a crazy man so I don't
really give a [ __ ]
sleeping next to naked girls he was a
great how old were they we're tying
young girls oh no he probably was
banging a lot of women young girls yeah
do dis a thing if we want to go we're
gonna ruin all our heroes in it
historians cuz if you want to go back
when Twitter social media and some of
the stuff correct it is also that was
kind of and again I'm not advocating any
of this and maybe it was a scumbag I
don't know let's say you was sleeping
with young girls but back then
especially when you say young girls
we're not talking about children oh no
no no we're talking about nineteen legal
yeah yeah and by the way in India back
then legal was fifteen sixteen like it
was everyone's day like like you know
like women were get married at fifty I'm
reading that book born standing up in
the time about how Johnny Carson wasn't
a fan of women's comedy he didn't think
they could deliver like men could so he
didn't want him on the show ever like
yeah because like I just I don't find it
as entertaining as as the men I think
women should do other things and then if
he if he was a Tonight Show host now he
would get kicked off here for saying
that but back then that was alright in
that parameter this historical
progression yes that's right we
shouldn't [ __ ] drag no I start like
when what about John Wayne there's
historical progression we're learning
that you know remember slavery I always
remind people slavery was actually the
order of the day owning human beings
selling their children black black it
black of course black and white I mean
in Greece you own slaves Aristotle the
great moral and philosophical thinkers
of our time never really talked about
slavery it's one of the things to story
and say the Buddha Muhammad Jesus
Moses all these people Socrates they
never talked about slavery as being evil
these it was normal for them it was just
the way it was yeah I'm gonna fire you
real quick again because it says Gandhi
did sleep with young women some still
teenagers yeah one of them was his own
grandniece okay slept naked with him at
night in bed yeah little Michael Jackson
vibe going on no no they were they were
like they were like back then in India
they were 15 see they were they were
they were you know women who are who
could be married remember
back there in India when you were 14 13
I'm just saying what the culture was and
most of the world when you hit puberty
you were married and arranged marriages
in India happened when you were 2 year
old to to be were nine years old and
then once she had her first period she
was able to have sex with the older
husband I'm just telling you what the
customs were in most of the long range
again we go back to its normal see
they're correct we go back to what these
things happen how these things were so
you have to do you have to put that into
context and that's what bothers me about
the movie 300 if it was historically
correct yeah they would raid the town
and then [ __ ] the little boys in the men
I have a theory on that too though I
think that there were always gay people
in that in those and it was more
accepted but most of guys like you're at
a gay or not right so like I said back
then like that like the kings and stuff
which I'm sure still to this day a lot
of powerful men do this [ __ ] on the side
yeah they said they'd have like little
boys or sex slaves I'm sure you had
slaves and some of them were you did
what you wanted to those slaves human
beings were owned and that was that was
the the United States where all of us
live has been a country with slavery
longer than it has been country without
slavery Don dad something important
handi-vac though I want you over with it
that's the takeaway he did a lot of
funky [ __ ] did a lot of [ __ ] yeah and
then found gee you know yeah it's so
much fun do you know do you know who do
you know who started the you know the
abolition movement the idea of like
getting rid of slavery worldwide you
know who is responsible for for
spearheading that movement who do you
think it was what country did it come
out of it's weird
where where them where the anti-slavery
movement definitely not being organized
yes not England yes the abolitionist
England and they were they were
essentially with
would be considered right-wing
Christians they were they were they were
avenge a local Christians who said this
is wrong and through their organization
and force they were able to get the
British Navy to take to the seas and
basically capture slave traders free the
slaves and either hang the slave traders
or put them in jail have you heard I
will forget which political person is
talking about that but free who it is
you might have to lip chin but they're
saying that to make our wrongs right we
should Oh african-americans my
reparations reparations problem with
that is my family my family came from
Sicily and Ireland and they didn't have
any money it had nothing to do with
slavery so what are we talking about you
we can keep going back like I'm saying
you can keep going how far do we go back
exactly then what the Native American
like holed up in none of you then wheat
what exactly but but then the argument
there's the Native Americans do receive
payment exactly exactly exactly who pays
for it but the government does pay the
name of Americans but yes they do yeah
but they're not about the Jews correct I
mean there's everyone's enslaved well
this is led the Jews are like the Jews
who had their conference their
properties confiscated and and and then
you know the money was the German money
when they come skating they put their
money into Swiss banks a lot of them
have seen some of their money but not
can I say this and I hope this doesn't
upset people but so those Native
Americans that are getting reparations
they were getting reparations now they
have they still do they get government
yeah funding lot loans for colleges how
are they doing as a society you know
they've had some challenges mm-hmm yeah
members have challenges I don't think
reparations is the answer I don't think
that's the answer at all I don't think
it's an answer
in fact I think it does more damage also
but then they also they want to say get
rid of all you know everything that
reminds you of reparations and statues
and stuff like that but then it's like
well how far you want to go back because
with George wash and then we got rid of
all the guys on money one of the things
but that was the time not only that when
you said knowing that is it one of the
things you always hear is from both
sides left and right but one of them say
Oh Sheila Jackson people will say hey we
need to spend more money on poverty okay
the problem with that is that since the
New Deal I think something like three
trillion dollar system spent on poverty
programs in this country so it's not
just about the government spending money
on poverty there's that's not a creative
way to look at things it's not just
about taxing the very rich and giving it
to quote unquote the poor those ideas
have been tried forever
that's a they're very creative way to
solve quote-unquote poverty first of all
people don't stay in poverty a lot of
times sometimes they go out they come
out of poverty they start poor or they
get rid take them it all depends it's a
very complicated issue but I don't think
giving money to people based on their
ancestors suffering is what makes
warehousing well we do have so we have a
lot of we have a lot of rental housing
affordable housing projects we spend a
great deal of money on poverty there
could we still have poverty we saw
people who can't afford rent we said
possibly don't fire me you're fine [ __ ]
man hard man Robert II had a good ready
Hobbiton I got nervous I don't wanna be
fired I knew it yeah so I don't know
there's got to be a better way I thought
was interesting though but then I mean I
don't know how far back you would go to
make it right well that's the problem
and that's why reparations to me doesn't
make a lot of sense you know white
people are enslaved as well I'll see
different in America but but white
people and but all people were kidnapped
what stops labor was the nation-state
the foundation of the nation-state when
people were able have armies and protect
their their populace it was the Balkans
and places like that where people were
always sleep in slave comes from Slav I
believe which was the Slavs were the
widow enslaved all the time hey but then
also also include correct me if I'm
wrong B didn't a lot of Africans sell
African yes yeah so do you go back till
then because those guys sold them to
slavery in Africa was going on and now
not only the Kikuyu were selling the
Dumas I were so fearsome slave traders
the Masai were fierce and as the other
things still going on Middle East the
Middle East was always the Britain had
such a hard time getting rid of slavery
in Africa in North Africa and the Middle
East I mean it was a huge thing so yes
he's when talking about slavery was that
slavery was a world lunch and son it was
not a white the white black thing in the
United States is such a recent
that's a that's a recent one that last
50 years right I mean while you're
talking about the past 200 you know 300
years but but but way before that there
was slavery and up until really the 70s
in the world slavery was was there was a
great deal slavery in the Middle East
you know to the south I was read I see
when I was living in Saudi Arabia my
mother said to me I remember this I was
a young boy she goes I was 13 my mom
said 12 she said don't tell you know
there's still slavery there's
essentially slavery in this country and
around here there's still in there are
still slaves and that was a fact and the
British had a [ __ ] of a time
getting the Ottoman Empire the Turks to
get rid of slavery they were like what
the [ __ ] you to our economy everything's
based on flavor what do you mean almost
all societies right like you this way my
knees the job harder resent in China
100% it was they do when you came into a
country and you conquered that country
you always enslaved the men the women
and children the men you killed if they
benefits if you couldn't slave them you
and say them but they're in in
Constantinople which was now modern-day
Istanbul when when the Turks took over
Constantinople which was a Christian
stronghold and they broke those walls
down and was standing there for a
thousand years with that cannon they
enslaved something like a hundred and
fifty thousand people leaving that we
can go back even now look at Isis Isis
that's what they were just kind of [ __ ]
now but correct when they were rampant
and they would take over town take the
way they slave all the children [ __ ] all
the women kill most the men sometimes
unfortunately it's like last week yeah
that was the order of the day and the
crazy [ __ ] remember is nobody really
enjoyed in Mohammed why didn't the
Buddha why didn't Harris tatl Socrates
weren't in the greatest minds of our
time why do they ever talk about the
norm it was the norm it was kind of
considered what you did it was kind of
considered like you took that birth this
time around you just took that birth
you're it's your turn to be a slave it's
my trying to be a nobleman that's why
doesn't make you right bro you are a
nobleman in England or anywhere else it
was called the great chain of being you
you were you had royal Bloods you only
you could only hang with people who had
the kind of blood you had you wouldn't
contaminate the caste system
you're in India the caste isn't that
stood forever was the table at the top
yeah the Untouchables the very bottom
everybody in the middle and you didn't
you didn't intermarry I mean and then
the account system is outlawed in India
you're fired
it's too long you're fine you watch
history your back tired
current events karna vets pervaiz man
did you watch the fight yeah yeah poured
Intel yeah yeah but or hey Mazz got such
a bad love for a do you think he he's
got his hands full with like everybody
but Jorge Mossville those is such a
[ __ ] sick striker the question is he
did get put on his back which I thought
was interesting by tell like he well no
he got knocked us yeah I got knocked his
burger they told on him yeah he took
till down his is I would like to see
what he's so [ __ ] good he's so good
yeah and what I thought was interesting
about him with till was he changed his
game up a little bit like he changed up
blues in that first round yeah but then
he came back and hot him and yes change
- so this teenager no have you seen this
be recorded himself
smashing an egg over an Australian
senators head yeah this is a New Zealand
he's kind of a right-wing guy huh well
it talks about immigration as being a
problem so the senator is from Australia
and he was speaking about the shooting
that happened in New Zealand and blaming
it on immigration but he's a white guy a
white American who did it no I I don't
know if it was a white American it was a
white dude yeah there's a white
supremacist like yeah yeah a disturbed
not funny human being yeah that the
problem with this is when you have some
psycho sociopath who decides to kill a
bunch of people who's obviously deeply
disturbed
everybody starts pointing the fingers at
your policy and that it's also possible
this guy's evil and crazy and it was
gonna [ __ ] is there something to this be
so after so in Australia right they had
that huge
automatic rifle mass shooting the next
day they ban automatic rifle well they
did our whole guns don't have a shoot
right they don't have any more mass
shootings New Zealand this happened
while
the next day banned assault rifles the
whole guns banned and I think they're
they haven't done it yet but they're
talking about gonna do it yeah in
America we have so many problems and
we're just like that's what we do see we
just did so so when know so you could
clearly realize like all I'm saying is
that in Vegas that guy killed what it
wound did 500 people yeah but you could
kill I'm gonna make call right now in
this country you could have a guy come
in with with weaponry you got seven guys
they could kill three thousand people
with guns for sure and I promise you
what you just did that people go hmm so
I don't dance till we're because nobody
knows we're kind of [ __ ] we're just
gonna keep happening cuz there's there's
so many guns down in our culture in our
environment it's a part of the American
society it's kind of like and I'm a gun
owner well so am i hears but you know
when I became a gun owner well my house
got broken into I called the cops and
they took so long to get that went I'll
[ __ ] I'm on my own that's right and it's
like it's not against the cops it's just
they have so much so much on their plate
that that was the fast they get that
went all [ __ ] that well that's not
gonna work my entire family be dead by
then guys well that's I got to get again
also but but but you know so so you have
a right to carry guns
Oh carry our own guns no prob okay fine
I own guns I understand I was just
shooting in [ __ ] Sonoma here's my
thing I also kind of have a right to
relax when I'm in a public area don't I
my mother and I never relaxed about any
women really go to public areas every
time I go to a [ __ ] I go the mall
know the movies with my so I think about
thing I do I go if the shooter comes
there I'm gonna go out this way every
day and then I'm gonna go here we're in
a dot like is the first thing I think
that's how I hear about the gunman at
Century City the other day I go to I so
when I lived there I used to go that
mall every weekend what happened there
was a guy waving a gun around no
shooting uh I don't know they know
nobody was shot he just kind of like
waved it around look so people knew that
he had a gun
fortunately nobody was hurt but I mean
nothing is to stop somebody you know
it's amazing it's not more often what
happens all the time dude there's more
mass shootings than there are days
yeah I don't know man
Oh a different mo this time and no one
has the answer
possibly an Asian dude I thought there
was no sign on Asia just anybody is
mentally disturbed it's that easy to get
a [ __ ] gun but I just don't get why
we don't take a page from Australia how
about this how about how about late how
about just have make it as hard to get a
gun as it is to get a driver's license
yeah so you had that leased assets that
same tried taking a driver license it's
Abby's you gotta wait in line do you
really want it that bad if I'm a kid you
know a lot of six-year-olds are saying
[ __ ] about uber everywhere most kids
don't even like I don't care yeah but
Oberer why would I want a car right
takes way too long but also like look at
how many [ __ ] gun accidents cause
people don't have their guns and safes
some crazy number of kids shoot
themselves that's terrible so people
just aren't educated with their guns I
don't know the answer what else we got
you want to see him get hit with egg
yeah it's inert one shot seems max about
races yeah look out this kids kind of
worried early he's like ah [ __ ] you tell
you wants to do it please get this [ __ ]
it let's do this I smack
is that they pinned the kid down like
like he has a [ __ ] suicide bomb on
enough to do police he's reportedly been
released a fundraising page has already
been set up to collect donations to
cover the teenagers the kids you later
haha and to quote I'm walking that's not
cool you though is it no yeah I don't do
that to him alright but Han go back go
back to the last thing you were just on
Australian centre and who blamed the New
Zealand terror attack on Muslim
immigration was egged on to you by
simply older an event all right
can't be a gimmick I'm more to it than
that yeah but if he wasn't trying to
film it too if he just did it cuz he was
pissed off it would be different but
he's trying to feel himself do it it's
pretty hit like he's trying to be
popular yeah yeah well he got Papa
tented definitely why he's egg boy next
one yeah so Disney star Kyle Massey he
used to be on that show That's So Raven
he had so Ravus for allegedly saying
sexual explicit photos to minor dude
yeah tell me a third truth you know I
could tell you he does that look at that
guy he snapchatted a dick pic to a 13
year old girl that he met when she was
nine and just one oh my god just one or
is there thirty able dancer
wait was nine he met her when she was
nine they stayed in communications cuz
he promised her family that he would
help kind of Mentor her into acting okay
and he also said that he offered her
family the opportunity for her to come
stay with him here in LA one of him and
his girlfriend
so my try to get him to meet people and
kind of network within the industry I
feel like there's better people to
network with and now they're trying to
sue him for 1.5 million doesn't even
have 1.5 million I don't think so
probably god that's no good he looks
witness [ __ ] Wow
some people just got that look man yeah
what else you got
so due to a computer glitch people in
Louisiana got twice the amount of money
for their tax returns and now if you use
the money you have to pay for it back
that's [ __ ] up mm-hmm
so they're back trying to like reverse
the direct deposit and the direct
deposit is already gone they're now
issuing a bill to the laws sixty six
thousand taxpayer received more money
six million dollars back yeah they have
to give it back - bummer
Oh God yeah do a sermon do my favor
that's your mistake write it off but
they lost 26 million dollars a lot of
money that's a lot of money what else
you guys but so this monkey is going
viral because of how buff she is I saw
him and I've got buff I think for the
type of monkey she is she's buff look
sick but nothing like that albino monkey
that though the hairless ones but
nothing that mean whatever got shoulder
he's a balkan you know bulky [ __ ]
monkey shoulders is a terrible face yeah
but also get on my face yeah looks like
your crossfit go all right not impressed
what else you got this right here DMX so
I guess Kanye West is doing these Sunday
prayer services and my nights in the
woods he's a he's a girl with neck DMX
is it minutes late lives are at he lives
in around that area play it
do you see his daughter dancing
[Music]
keeping a special privileges to foster
he always is a wizard with his words
it's murder
then the beat just dropped chuckle you
know I went through a phase where I
listened to a lot of DMX really yeah I
like him you're fired
Thank You Cole please me no bombs
my skin can't take this I was younger I
was like getting my forties man come on
I was 40 my 40 yeah what else you dad um
well do you guys know this girl I just
barely found out who this girl is but
her name is Lilly Singh and she's just a
youtuber who got famous now she has her
own NBC night late-night show so what is
sing you know do you know what she could
where she comes from
Cindy Iranian yeah and what where in
India what is she I don't know she is a
Sikh
I sing me you taught you know you're
killing a YouTube star Lilly Singh is
ready to take on damn she has her own
late-night I got to have it on NBC good
for her man with all the big boys I've
seen her I've watched her YouTube
channel Wow I'm the one that big four
networks Jesus in Dean Canadian that's
coin Russell Peters she's gonna take
over for Carson Daly who stepped away
from last call yeah it's too bad cuz so
many people watching at 1:30 in the
morning it's true I knew I was in
trouble if Carson Daly shows like I'm up
way too late yeah well now I don't I
feel sick
also now that I watch the lawn when you
want listen that when you watch Fallon
then when they interview you're like you
they can't convince out Oh Oh old school
old school right like tell me what's
going on with your family 30 in 30
seconds yeah let's promote your movie
end you're out of here let's get to the
music out it's really kind of a good for
her though that's cool all right the
next one
Disney's rehired
The Guardian the galaxy director James
Gunn was fired because of old tweets
yeah yes but so many so many people on
the
the staff all the actors said they
weren't gonna do the move yeah it's not
part of it they love him because he's
such a he's the I guess he's behind it
so that's so cool well that was started
by a Michael of the [ __ ] that one person
yeah yeah he's a lawyer first Mountain
lawyer who's kind of a right wing guy
who found all the names gun back baby
starting to swing back the regular sorry
itch start a [ __ ]
yes yeah Michael start a [ __ ] right he
was like if you're in the game and you
want to dick is because he goes hard on
people like Roseanne Barr and stuff we
get [ __ ] up
so he goes bad on them on Twitter so
he's like really you want to go bad
let's see let's see your tweet but this
is a first step in the direction to
people getting their job and hired or
getting fired for like old tweets
well he's super left-wing so yeah he
definitely should be thanking I'll [ __ ]
tweets yeah I stopped seeing any other
guardians of the galaxy I heard leaders
really first one for sure second ones
I've ever seen I'm nervous you Wow
is it hot in here no it's so cold in
here oh you got a hospital for sherry on
that don't know I'm have one more don't
get don't know
all right do you guys know this girl
she's an actress
Carly Schroeder I know so she was from
Lizzie McGuire and she a bunch of TV
shows and she's like an up-and-coming
actress I'm not really up-and-coming she
has like a bunch of stuff on her plate
but she's giving it all up to go join
the army good she came to her senses
did she though yeah Oh like a damn
section the army is that her the little
one yeah the little rare I saw your boy
Tim Kennedy post oh that's right I did
see Tim post this yeah that's cool very
amazing Duff yeah that is Boyce you see
and that's her now yeah she did training
for like a TV show but she's gonna join
them come on that's cool you wanna watch
it you're good I'm good
good luck girl this was a little weird
so that shooter he named a guy named
PewDiePie who was like a huge YouTube
star but the last one of the last thing
he said
like make sure to subscribe to
PewDiePie's channel didn't get PewDiePie
get in trouble for reals comment first
saying the n-word and I think we have it
here this is what Davison marrow who I
love both these guys yeah the way he
says the n-word to is pretty aggressive
so he's playing a video game
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] whoa hoody say
flava dig his no Geoffrey star Jesus
could I remember that but that was just
so great I mean he caught himself saying
he's like oh [ __ ] like that's something
that's part of what he said so
outrageous yeah does it er though so
hard was a hard like that's not artists
but users don't drop that nah that was
weird
that was awkward yeah oh good another
quick one a mom is suing that one caught
the whole college channel thing for 500
billion dollars hey kitty it's a class
action so all the different families
involved oh $500 Wow hopefully they get
it I think I think that they're they're
really coming after Lawson too much I
think this like and they bragged about
this and I think you [ __ ] [ __ ]
are looking for clickbait it's like
let's just pile on cuz they're cowards
people I hate pylons look they [ __ ] up
they're facing the music but let's not
pile on you the sugar the media has
become gossipy high school [ __ ] I have
no respect for it
apparently they bragged about not going
school apparently they were [ __ ] shut
the [ __ ] up you gossipy [ __ ]
[ __ ] care mmm do you see the meme
that's going around with Lori Loughlin
no love just it's not even really a meme
it's just her and her daughter and there
was her daughter's YouTube channel she's
huge on YouTube where she was not as a
makeup girl yeah yeah it's a for and all
that she's like they did a thing with
the mom and her she's like I didn't pay
all this money for you to go to college
for you know not to like it or something
like that and they she was just like
laughs are they are they gonna do any
jail time for this federal 22 years no
no I don't know these are done these are
the amount of money in federal crime
yeah yeah they're investigating Rick
Caruso right now because when who is on
the
Board of Trustees at USC because when
the news broke Lori Loughlin daughter
was on his yacht with him and his family
because she's best friends with his
daughter and I have insight sources
since I went to USC that they actually
flew a helicopter to pick up Lori
Loughlin daughter and take her back on
land while the family pieced out yeah so
and shady going on there yeah from what
I heard he's not in the states right now
yikes I got a pee go for a pee I'm ass
oh no you do you guys want to just chill
this is the last one right yeah pretty
much wrap it all right well that was fun
man I made it through with sweating
through the whole thing
good job no one lost a job i watch
everyone's back tired yep proud of you
thank you I want to take a look at your
rump I want to make sure I want to get
in there for a little bit I got some
instruments you find surely fine well I
want to try it again nope you fine I
just want to check out your Irish nope
you're fired
damn it speaking of being fired I'll be
in Milwaukee this Friday and Saturday
yes Michelle Friday one show Saturday
Turner hall Theater this Friday and set
him in Milwaukee I get my boy
Derek post in and a sign from the county
store empty and open up for me come see
us this Friday and Saturday in Milwaukee
and then after that next week Washington
DC DC improv Thursday Friday Saturday
all the shows are most sold out so get
to youth right now chief at kake.com
Brian I'll be in Kansas City this
weekend me and Stevie blue eyes come
check us out Friday Saturday Kansas City
improv Philadelphia Saturday shows are
already sold out apparently so get your
tickets for Thursday Friday Philadelphia
at helium so looking forward to that
keep at kake.com hungry Calgary on April
4 and 5 and 6 come and see me you
[ __ ] and Calgary all right bye-bye
t pack a calm there's the fun kid we're
out